sure i mean you performed to like
thousands of people okay
it's your partner
it's okay
you know you can do it i get it i get
the fervor i get it with the torso oh
you're so sorry torso sorry sorry it's
okay you can eat it's not the same it's
not the same we get it it's yeah why do
koreans do that what zero to 100 in 1.5
seconds theatrics we're in theatrics you
know
yeah but culturally we do it too yeah
it's like even if i or watch
any korean movie it's always mumble
mumble mumble scream mambo stream
because our emotions are fluid
and
yeah we connect them all
so what you know koreans are extra
feelers like in star trek next
generation would be beta betazoid
i mean troy you don't what do you think
it just makes me upset that no one knows
what star trek next are they not as good
as like alpha zoids
no no beta's always the brace of people
that can feel other people's feelings
empaths
their empaths oh cool yeah yeah so in
the show they're empaths they're like an
mbti army right
yeah yeah
and so um
when i'm feeling all right like right
now i'm feeling
wild
and i feel content
hungry right
so i'm feeling this right now now if i
feel anger i it just bleeds into that
feeling but does the anger just come out
of nowhere
and it just sticks its head out yeah
but i do i don't do it to strangers
because my dad used to do that scream at
people
yeah he would call i mean he he swung a
golf club
to two big like i think they're mexicans
but
right he went hey
and they took a [ __ ] golf club and
started swinging at them i remember
being in the car scared so it's like
damn i don't want to do that in public
sure
you didn't i don't think that that was
fine
that that you came you still came at a
great distance yeah yeah yeah and a
coveted safe korean theater
yeah i've no idea yeah yeah i also felt
you weren't in danger i mean i looked at
your eyes no right it's your fault
you're calling you're causing drama
no no no kalila's watching out she's
looking out yeah
i apologize for that i come from a
screamy household what chinese people
don't have that
um
[Music]
i i don't know if it's the same like
what you're talking about with koreans
like with the mama mama and then but i
feel like there there's a distinct
separation between like one it's like
it's like normal and then they're just
like pissed like i feel like you have to
get there yeah like you have to say like
i never liked you dad
you know yeah yeah like go like crazy
yeah do you ever say that to your dad
when i was really young once i was like
dad i love you but i don't like you ooh
yeah what was his reaction he was he got
upset he was upset oh my god it was like
it was like oh you you don't have to
like that kind of thing yeah because if
i said that to my dad
you know dad i love you but i don't like
you the first thing i would hear
is
that's my conscious going off oh you
turn off yeah yeah yeah you know how
like a android or whatever when they get
shut off yeah i see that in my eye yeah
right right right and then maybe
two or three hours later i wake up
and i think i'm laying there i have a
black eye oh
i'm never gonna say i like that's how i
learned i'm never gonna say that to him
again
your dad was never violent
um not past a certain age i mean not and
not violent i think he was definitely
disciplinary and
yeah yeah i would tell my mom i loved
her and she'd still punch me in the
mouth oh oh yeah
but yeah i'm so sorry babe yeah that
sucks but i think
[Laughter]
you should have what did you feel though
you should have died yeah did you feel
that yeah yeah yeah
i think it makes you the type person you
are cognizant right
of
looming dangers yeah
right i'm always like bracing and yeah
yeah for that change and
you never know when a backhand is around
the corner yeah i know yeah yeah i'm
skittish yeah but you can always tell
when somebody was raised good i think
can you or no um
i i can tell when someone's been raised
has never been hit
like violently
they're a little bit more like less
skittish like when i look at george
kimmel i'm like oh there was love and
stability and like kindness i could tell
that too ah yeah he's very even keeled
he doesn't have a lot of like really
terrible days throughout the year is
this true yeah oh okay good he's a happy
guy
yeah he's just the type of guy that i
can call him and i've done this before
24 7. oh
i feel like an [ __ ] saying this
say it
no matter what he's doing i'll just go i
need yellow american spirits
like i'm helping my child and he's on
the other side of town